[Music]
if you've been dreaming of an Avengers
video games since the superhero movies
kicked off their domination at the box
office then you're about to get exactly
what you want square enix and Marvel
have announced a multi-game partnership
the first of which is for an Avengers
game I'm Matt and this gamespot news
update is here to save the day The
Avengers game is being made by tomb
raider developer crystal dynamics and
deus ex studio a dose montreal all we
have to go on is a teaser trailer that
shows off Thor's hammer Iron Man's
gauntlet and Captain America's shield we
can hear the Hulk having a bad day in
the background while an unidentified
woman says they say the time of heroes
is over that if you're different you're
dangerous but I know the truth the world
will always need heroes we just need to
reassemble code-named the avengers
project it's set to feature an original
story and will introduce a universe
gamers can play in for years to come but
don't get too excited we won't hear any
more details about the avengers project
or other marble games from Square Enix
until 2018 we'll keep you updated as
more is revealed before more news from
around the world of video games stay
tuned to gamespot
you
you